hi everybody welcome back to archive
insights so lately we've seen a lot of
new emerging algorithms in deep
reinforcement learning and in this
episode I want to dive into one specific
algorithm called proximal policy
optimization that was designed at
opening eye and has proven successful on
a wide variety of tasks going all the
way from robotic control to Atari and
even playing complicated video games
like dota 2 now in this episode I'm
gonna dive into some pretty technical
terrain so I think it's good if you're a
little bit prepared I've made a few
previous videos with an introduction to
reinforcement learning and the problem
of the sparse reward setting so I think
if you're kind of new to the field of
reinforcement learning I would suggest
to watch those videos first and then
come back to this video as we're going
to dive pretty deep into the rabbit hole
and being well-prepared definitely as a
must for this video but if you think
you're ready for it grab a cup of coffee
and get ready to dive in deep because
this episode is on proximal policy
optimization my name is Xander and
welcome to our kevinsites
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right so let's start by sketching
some surroundings first so if we're
doing supervised learning on a data set
like image net for example then we can
have a static training data set we can
run a circus in gradient descent
optimizer in that data and we can be
pretty sure that our model will converge
to a pretty decent local optimum the
road to success in reinforcement
learning however isn't that simple so
one of the problems that reinforcement
learning suffers from is that the
training data that is generated is
itself dependent on the current policy
because our agent is generating its own
training data by interacting with the
environment rather than relying on a
static data set as is the case in
supervised do and so this means that the
data distributions of our observations
and rewards are constantly changing as
our agent learns which is a major cause
of instability in the whole training
process an apart from having this
problem with varying training data
distributions reinforcement learning
also suffers from a very high
sensitivity to hyper parameter tuning
and things like initialization for
example and in some cases it's kind of
intuitive to understand why this happens
because imagine that your learning rate
is too large well then you could have a
policy update that pushes your policy
network into a region of the parameter
space where it's going to collect the
next batch of data under a very poor
policy causing it to never recover again
and so to address many of these annoying
problems in reinforcement learning the
team and opening I designed a new
reinforcement learning algorithm that's
called proximal policy optimization or
PPO and the core purpose behind PPO was
to strike a balance between ease of
implementation sample efficiency and
ease of tuning now the first thing to
realize about PPO is that it is what we
call a policy gradient method and this
means that unlike popular key learning
approaches like dqn for example that can
learn from stored offline data proximal
policy optimization learns online and
this means that it doesn't use a replay
buffer to store past experiences but
instead it learns directly from whatever
its agent encounters in the environment
and once a batch of experience has been
used to do a gradient update the
experience is then discarded and the
policy moves on and this also means that
policy gradient methods are typically
less sample efficient than queue
learning methods because they only use
the
collected experience once for doing an
update and our general policy
optimization methods usually start by
defining the policy gradient laws as the
expectation over the log of the policy
actions times an estimate of the
advantage function okay so what is that
only well the first term pi theta is our
policy it's a neural network that takes
the observed States from the environment
as an input and suggests actions to take
as an output and the second term is the
advantage function a which basically
tries to estimate what the relative
value is of the selected action in the
current state so let's take apart what
that means so in order to compute the
advantage we need two things we need to
discounted sum of rewards and we need a
baseline estimate so the first part is
the discounted sum of rewards or the
return and this is basically a weighted
sum of all the rewards the agent Gaad
during each time step in the current
episode and then the discount factor
gamma which is usually somewhere between
0.9 and 0.99 accounts for the fact that
your agent cares more about reward that
is going to get very quickly versus the
same reward it would get a hundred times
that for now and this is exactly the
same idea as interest in the financial
world in the sense that getting money
tomorrow is usually more valuable than
getting the same amount of money say a
year from now and so notice that the
advantage is calculated after the
episode sequence was collected from the
environment so in other words we know
all the rewards so there is no guessing
involved in computing the discount or
return because we actually know what
happened okay so that was the first part
of the advantage function the discounted
sum of rewards and then the second part
of the advantage function is the
baseline or the value function and
basically what the value function tries
to do is give an estimate of the
discounted sum of rewards from this
point onward so basically it's trying to
guess what the final return is going to
be in this episode starting from the
current state and during training this
neural net that's representing the value
function is going to be frequently
updated using the experience that our
agent collects in the environment
because this is basically a supervised
learning problem you're taking States as
an input and your neural net is trying
to predict what the discounted sum of
rewards is going to be from this state
onwards so basic supervised learning and
notice that because this value estimate
is the output of a neural net this is
gonna be a noisy estimate there's gonna
be some variance because our network is
not going to always predict the exact
value of that states so basically we're
going to end up with a noisy estimate of
the value function okay so now we have
the two terms that we need we have the
discounted sum of rewards that we
computed from our episode rollout and we
have an expectation an estimate of that
value given the state that we're in and
if we then subtract the baseline
estimate from the actual return we got
we get what we call the advantage
estimate and so basically the advantage
estimate is answering the question how
much better was the action that I took
based on the expectation of what would
normally happen in the state that I was
in so basically was the action that our
agent took was it better than expected
or was it worse and so then by
multiplying the log probabilities of
your policy actions with this advantage
function we get the final optimization
objective that is used in policy grading
and if you think about what this
objective function is doing it's
intuitively satisfying because if the
advantage estimate was positive meaning
that the actions that the agent took in
the sample trajectory resulted in better
than average return what we'll do is
we'll increase the probability of
selecting them again in the future when
we encounter in the same state and if on
the other hand the advantage function
was negative then we'll reduce the
likelihood of the selected actions which
makes total sense right and as I've
already mentioned one of the problems is
that if you simply keep running gradient
descent on one batch of collected
experience what will happen is that
you'll update the parameters in your
network so far outside of the range
where this data was collected that for
example the advantage function which is
you know in principle a noisy estimate
of the real advantage is going to be
completely wrong and so in a sense
you're just going to destroy your policy
if you keep running gradient descent on
a single batch of collected experience
and I'll to solve this issue one
successful approach is to make sure that
if you're updating the policy you're
never going to move too far away from
the old policy now this idea was widely
introduced in a paper called trust
region policy optimization or T RPO
which is actually the whole basis on
which PPO was built and so here is the
objective function that was used in T
RPO and if you compare this we
the previous objective function for
vanilla policy gradients what you can
see is that the only thing that changed
in this formula is that the log operator
is replaced with the division by PI
theta old now the slide here shows that
optimizing this TR Pio objective is in
fact identical to vanilla policy
gradients I'm not going to go into the
derivation details here but if you want
you can pause the video or check out
lecture 5 of the deep RL bootcamp which
will take you deep down the rabbit hole
link in the description now to make sure
that the updated policy doesn't move too
far away from the current policy TRP row
adds a KL constraint to the optimization
objective and what this Cal constrained
effectively does is it's just going to
make sure that the new updated policy
doesn't move too far away from the old
policy so in a sense we just want to
stick close to the region where we know
everything works fine the problem is
that this Cal constraint adds additional
overhead to our optimization process and
can sometimes lead to very undesirable
training behavior so wouldn't it be nice
if we can somehow include this extra
constraint directly into our
optimization objective well as you might
have guessed that is exactly what PPO
does ok so now that we have a little bit
of surroundings let's dive into the crux
of the algorithm the central
optimization objective behind PPO hold
on to your heads it's about to get a
little technical the first let's define
a variable R theta which is just a
probability ratio between the new
updated policy outputs and the outputs
of the previous old version of the
policy Network so given a sequence of
sampled actions and States this R theta
value will be larger than 1 if the
action is more likely now than it was in
the old version of the policy and it
will be somewhere between 0 and 1 if the
action is less likely now than it was
before the last gradient step and then
if we multiply this ratio R theta with
the advantage function we get the normal
TRP or objective in a more readable form
and with this notation we can finally
write down the central objective
function that is used in PP oh here it
is look surprisingly simple right well
first of all you can see that the
objective function that PPO optimizes is
an expectation operator so this means
that we're going to compute this over
batches of trajectories and this
expectation operator is taken over the
minimum of two terms the first of these
terms is R theta times the advantage
estimate so this is the default
objective for normal policy gradients
which pushes the policy towards actions
that yield a high positive advantage
over the baseline now the second term is
very similar to the first one except
that it contains a truncated version of
this R theta ratio by applying a
clipping operation between 1 minus
epsilon and 1 plus epsilon where epsilon
is usually something like 0.2 and then
lastly the min operator is applied to
the two terms to get the final result
and while this function looks rather
simple at first sight fully appreciating
all the subtleties at work here takes a
little bit more effort so bear with me
here I promise we're almost there
firstly it's important to note that the
advantage estimate can be both positive
and negative and this changes the effect
of the main operator here is a plot of
the objective function for both positive
and negative values of the advantage
estimate so on the left half of the
diagram where the advantage function is
positive or all the cases where the
selected action had a
better-than-expected effect on the
outcome and on the right half of the
diagram we can find situations where the
action had an estimated negative effect
on the outcome now on the left side
notice how the loss function flattens
out when R gets too high and this
happens when the action is a lot more
likely under the current policy than it
was under the old policy and in this
case we don't want to overdo the action
update too much and so the objective
function gets clipped here to limit the
effect of the gradient update and then
on the right side where the action had
an estimated negative value the
objective flattens when R goes near zero
and this corresponds to actions that are
much less likely now than in the old
policy and it will have the same effect
of not overdoing a similar update which
might otherwise reduce these action
probabilities to zero remember the
advantage function is noisy so we don't
want to destroy a policy based on a
single estimate
and finally what about the very right
hand side well the objective function
only ends up in this region when the
last gradient step made the selected
action a lot more probable so are as big
while also making our policy worse since
the advantage is negative here and if
that's the case then we would really
want to undo the last gradient step and
it just so happens that the objective
function in PPO allows us to do this the
function is negative here so the
gradient will tell us to walk the other
direction and make the action less
probable by an amount proportional to
how much we screwed it up in the first
place and also notice that this is the
only region where the unclipped part of
the objective function has a lower value
than the clipped version and those gets
returned by the minimization operator
pretty clever right and if you're
wondering how on earth the authors from
the PPO paper managed to design this
specific reward function well it's quite
likely that they had an intuitive idea
of what they wanted the objective
function to do so they probably sketched
a bunch of diagrams that satisfied the
behavior that we just discussed and then
came up with the exact objective
function to make it all work out and
don't worry if you didn't fully get all
the little details involved basically
the PPO objectives does the same as a
TRP all objective and that it forces the
policy updates to be conservative if
they move very far away from the current
policy the only difference is that PPO
does this with a very simple objective
function that doesn't require to
calculate all these additional
constraints or KL divergences and in
fact it turns out that the simple PPO
objective function often outperforms the
more complicated variant that we have in
T RPO simplicity often wins all right
nice now that we've seen the central
objective function behind PPO let's take
a look at the entire algorithm end to it
so as mentioned before there are two
alternating threads in PPO in the first
one the current policy is interacting
with the environment generating episode
sequences for which we immediately
calculate the advantage function using
our fitted baseline estimate for the
state values and then every so many
episodes a second thread is going to
collect all that experience and run
gradient descent on the policy network
using the clips PPO object
and as was done in training the opening
i-5 system these two threats can
actually be decoupled from each other by
using thousands of remote workers that
interact with the environment using a
recent copy of the policy Network and a
GPU cluster that runs gradient descent
on the network weights using the
collected experience from those workers
note that in this case each worker has
to refresh its local copy of the policy
network pretty often to make sure that
it's always running with the latest
version of the policy network to keep
everything nicely balanced now
importantly the final loss function that
is used to Train an agent is the sum of
this clips PPO objective that we just
saw plus two additional terms the first
additional term of the loss function is
basically in charge of updating the
baseline network so this is the part of
the network graph that is in charge of
estimating how good it is to be in this
state or more specifically what is the
average amount of this counted reward
that I expect to get from this point
onwards so even though the value and
policy outputs form two separate heads
of the same network because they are
part of the same computation graph you
can actually combine everything in a
single loss function and the auto
differentiation library will just figure
out where to send all the gradients and
the reason that these two lost terms are
actually part of the same objective
function is that the value estimation
network shares a large portion of its
parameter space with the policy Network
and the intuition is that whether you're
trying to you know estimate the value of
the current state or you simply want to
take the best current action well you're
likely going to need very similar
feature extraction pipelines from the
current state observation so these parts
of the network are simply shared and
then finally the last term in the
objective function is called the entropy
term and this term is in charge of
making sure that our agent does enough
exploration during training so in
contrast to discrete action policies
that output the action choice
probabilities the people your policy
head
outputs the parameters of a Gaussian
distribution for each available action
type and when running the agent and
training mode the policy will then
sample from these distributions to get a
continuous output value for each action
head now if you want to fully understand
why the
entropy term encourages exploration I
really recommend to check out ugly
Angelo's video on the ideas behind
entropy and KL divergence in machine
learning the link is in the description
but basically the entropy of a
stochastic variable which is driven by
an underlying probability distribution
is the average amount of bits that is
needed to represent its outcome it is a
measure of how unpredictable an outcome
of this variable really is and so
maximizing its entropy will force it to
have a wide spread over all the possible
options resulting in the most
unpredictable outcome and so this gives
some intuition as to why adding an
entropy term will push the policy to
behave a little bit more randomly until
the other parts of the objective start
dominating and as always we have a
couple of hyper parameters C 1 and C 2
that way the contributions of these
different parts in the loss function now
for people that want to take a deeper
look at PEO in terms of Python code
I really recommend to check out this
implementation in PI towards from our L
adventure trust me even though you've
never worked with PI torch this
implementation is as clean as it gets
and if you're looking for a more
production proof implementation I would
recommend to check out opening eye
baselines which has a full implemented
tensorflow version that runs on
different environments like Atari Mojo
Co and others both links are in the
description all right so that's it
congratulations if you've made it this
far we've covered all you need to know
about proximal policy optimization now
in the paper you can find a bunch of
graphs that compare PPO to other
benchmarks in deep RL so don't hesitate
to have a look the link is in the
description the important thing to
remember though is that PPO wasn't
specifically designed for sample
efficiency but rather to address the
really complicated code that was needed
for a lot of other algorithms and also
you know making it relatively easy to
tune in terms of high performers and
because PPO achieves both of those
objectives while also yielding close to
or above state-of-the-art performance on
a wide range of tasks it has become one
of the benchmarks in deep reinforcement
learning
so in summary PPO is a state of the art
policy gradient method the algorithm has
the stability and reliability of T RPO
while
much simpler to implement requiring only
a few tweaks to vanilla policy gradient
methods and it can be used for a wide
range of reinforcement learning tasks
great or before I end this video I would
really like to thank all the people that
support this channel on patreon I mean
even if it's only $1 a month those
contributions really mean a lot to me
they are a big motivation because they
show that the people out there really
care for the content that I'm making and
it's a really good motivation to keep
going so thanks a lot all my great
amazing patreon supporters if wha that
was it for this episode thank you very
much for watching I hope you learned
something about proximal policy
optimization don't forget to Like
subscribe and share and I'd love to see
you again in the next episode of
archived insights
[Music]